allez y lève toi bonjour brillant stefan
füle a conscience que
toi qui as vous
dans un doctorat de physique
salut salut je suis en sciences ou en
art
je suis cosmologistes c'est quoi ça
j'étudie le mariage de l'espace et du
temps
le couple parfait
on ne sait jamais d'où surgira la
prochaine avancée ni qui l'a frappé
et si l'inversé le temps pour savoir ce
qui a pu se passer au commencement
remonter le camp remonter le temps
continue
j'ignore comment pour l'instant
quand tu n'as de remonter un jusqu'où
oh
ça s'appelle la sclérose latérale
amyotrophique l'espérance de vie est de
deux ans ce peu de temps tu nous reste
que le vivre près de thouars ce truc va
tout changer
tu ne te rends pas compte de ce qui
t'attend ce sera vraiment dévastateurs
mais je laime
est il même lui aussi nous allons lutter
ensemble contre cette maladie
bonne chance comment ça va plutôt bien
didon cette histoire de trous noirs au
début du temps c'est brillant très
brillant stephen bravo docteur il a une
pneumonie
la seule solution pour qu'il survive
s'est pratiqué une trachéotomie et ne
pourra plus jamais parler mais s'il
parlera je m'appelle stéphen au crime la
voie n'est pas joli c'est un problème je
suis très heureux d'avoir pu voir cet
homme relever tous les défis tant sur le
plan scientifique que sur le plan
personnel
rien ne doit l'imiter
l'activité humaine
aussi terrible soit la vie s'il ya de la
vie il ya de l'espoir
merci désolé tu as dis quelque chose je
dis merci